with billions of dollars in debt and
moist of its fleet grounded the
announcement surprised few Virgin
Australia handed over its books to
insolvency firm Deloitte as board
members placed it in administration
it's the largest global airline to
collapse so far under the shock of the
corona virus outbreak this is not just
something that is hurting birds in
Australia we know it's hurting the
industry globally and is the worst
aviation crisis we've ever seen in our
district the company will continue to
operate while it's being restructured
but it leaves nearly 16,000 people in
Australia uncertain about their jobs at
a time when unemployment is rising due
to covert 19 shutdowns and a global
recession becoming a near-certain
reality most staff had already been
stood down due to flights being canceled
for weeks the airline has been urging
the government to line at hundreds of
millions of dollars to survive the
crisis but it's refused saying it won't
bail out a company that's 90 percent
owned by foreign shareholders with big
pockets if the airline suspends
operations the national carrier Qantas
would have a near monopoly in Australia
which many say would be in nobody's
interest the Australian government has
to take an industry-wide perspective on
this and they really do need to support
both version Australia now it's an
administration with some sort of support
and also Qantas Virgin Australia remains
optimistic it will survive and says
there's been interest from foreign
investors Richard Branson who co-founded
virgin and owns 10% of the Australian
arm tweeted this is not the end of
Virgin Australia but I believe a new
beginning the question is whether it
will be an attractive investment when
borders remain closed and the industry
is under pressure
worldwide Nicola gage al Jazeera Sydney